in level but you never cook again back
please always push it over to the brain
never respect your respect back
reach reach that is you'll be fine
[Music]
controversially I award the Dark Knight
strikes again part 1 as 7 out of 10 I
really enjoyed the groundwork that the
book could put in and its introduction
of Batman is one of the best within
comics
yeah the book as a whole still has a bad
reputation I'm happy to say that I now
know why opening on news in the nude
book too quickly destroys all the
goodwill of the prior entry established
it's like going on the first day with an
alcoholic you're getting on fine a
couple of drinks couple of shots and
it's going well then she decides to get
the sound Booker's out within 20 minutes
she's pissed herself vomited on your
shoulder stub the tab out on your willy
wonka don't really know what happened to
Frank Miller between these two boots but
I'm guessing it was heavy doses of
heroin for legal purposes I have to say
allegedly throughout the story the news
clips completely derail the poor acting
more as random sound bites the narrative
devices and it makes the book harder to
read than Michael J Fox is handwriting
within the first six pages of the book
we are given three double-page spreads
and whilst in comics like Justice League
and forever evil these are used to great
effect to show a wealth of wonder and
grandeur here it's to fill up time one
of them is just a Batmobile in the sky
against the CGI background and the
others look like what you hand in for
your final art exam when you've not
really put in any time to it because
you've been studying for your actual
exams this book especially is filled
with them every time something dramatic
happens you can bet it's going to take
up seven huge splash pages Clarke and
Wonder Woman making love v splash pages
Batman taking down Lex Luthor boss
splash pages well it doesn't seem like
even the writer is invested in telling
an intricate story I don't see why the
reader should waste their time gone is
the airtight compressed storytelling
from The Dark Knight Returns and it's
replaces what looked like a bunch of
sketches and hot finished ideas this
reads like a slideshow just
just everything whizzing past tell him
stop and burst out hammer time instead
of Miller time on this book that doesn't
work as a joke after the dark night
completely dismantles his operation Lex
Luthor wants revenge unleashing the
Brainiac ship upon metropolis Superman
is the only one who can stop it after
threatening to destroy Condor if he
should flee the Man of Steel steps down
allowing himself to lose whilst this
would be a signifying moment of the last
son of Krypton's nobility it's so slowly
told that becomes hard to digest I try
to really sink my teeth into the meat of
the story but the sourness of it left a
bad taste in my mouth
food comes in on the plot Luthor was
actually attacking the city in using
Superman as a pawn in order to draw
Batman out of course the world's
greatest detective is preempted this and
doesn't take the bait
instead we are introduced to Lara the
daughter of Superman and Wonder Woman
she mercilessly destroys the Brainiac
ship and it's a nice introduction even
if she isn't that likable of a character
unfortunately one of the biggest
problems of this issue is that it
doesn't have much focus on Batman once
the initial issue used to absence of the
Caped Crusader a build-up to his
eventual return this one seems to be
missing him because there isn't much you
can do
close to 60 is almost useless in
fighting these bigger threats enjoy this
the tone of the book and the narrative
devices actually shift more towards
Superman than they do The Dark Knight so
thin that would be absolutely fine if
the book didn't feel like it was written
by a three year old how the mighty have
fallen
I don't know whether it's the piss-poor
or the poorly paced story or the 697
splash pages but this is a really bad
comic issue losing all of the weight and
social commentary that made the Dark
Knight Returns so good this almost feels
pornographic in its poor taste and use
of women as
objects at least porn has a good story
so I'm told in case my girlfriend's
watching this this feels completely
alien to all of the good work that
Miller's had done in the past it's
completely directionless it's a jumble
of ideas that this pile on top of each
other to the point that the execution of
a good storyline becomes almost
impossible bad from start to finish I
have no other choice but to award this
issue 310 yeah so what did you think of
the issue especially in comparison to
the first one which was actually quite
good well let me know make sure you
subscribe because next week I'm doing
the final issue of the dark light
strikes again and then we've been
building up to it it's my review of The
Dark Knight 3 so make sure you stay
tuned thanks very much for checking out
this video take care peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]